We assert the correctness of the
reduction with the following theorem.
Consider a bipartite graph G and
the associated flow network F,
which we just constructed.
The edges in G which have flows of
1 in a maximum flow obtained by
Ford-Fulkerson on F constitute a maximum
matching in the original graph G.
To prove this theorem,
we start by observing that the flow
across any edge is either 0 or 1.
Any augmenting path will have
a bottleneck capacity of 1.
Remember all capacities are 1.
So we'll always augment flows by 1.
But 1 is also the maximum flow
that can go across any edge.
The conservation of flow then
implies that each vertex
is in at most one edge that we return.
On the left hand side, we only have
one unit of capacity going in, so
we can't have more than one
unit of capacity going out.
So each vertex on the left hand side
will be included in at most one edge.
And similarly, for
the right hand side, we have,
at most, one unit of flow going out.
So we can have, at most, one unit of
flow going in, which implies that every
vertex on the right will be involved in,
at most, one matched edge or output.
This means that the set of edges
in the original graph that have
flow 1 in the flow network
constitute a matching.
Is it a maximum matching?
Well, if there were a larger matching,
it would be trivial to
construct a larger flow.
Just give those edges flow 1 in here,
and connect them with out flow values
of 1 to the source, and the one on the
right with flow values of 1 to the sync.
So yes, it must be a maximum matching.